of the United Kingdom and The
Commonwealth
which is
it is with great Sorrows that the French
people have learned of the death of a
Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
her wisdom and empathy have helped us
all to steer a path through the historic
ups and downs of the last seven decades
with her passing we all feel an
emptiness
millions of people around the world
discovered the images of a coronation
and were immediately captivated by the
young leader who already exhibited such
strengths and courage
the courage of Life marked by the war
and soon the courage to uphold from one
century to the next the values of
freedom and tenacity
her rare and powerful words
her unwavering dignity
made her the constant symbol of the
United Kingdom
we are grateful for her deep affection
for France
Elizabeth II mastered our language loved
our culture
and touched our hearts
from her coronation on she knew and
spoke with all of our presence
no other country had the privilege of
welcoming her as many times as we did
in her
I have known a great head of state
a unique example of her Devotion to her
people
and a very close Ally
with her
France and the United Kingdom shared not
just an Anton cordial
but a warm sincere
and loyal partnership
to you
she was your queen
to us
she was the queen
to us all
she would be with us forever
we will remember and perpetuate the
values she never ceased to embody and
promote
the moral fortitude of democracy and
freedom
at this sad moment
we send our heartfelt condolences to his
majesty the king
the royal family the British people
and all those who loved the queen
and will miss her so deeply